geister schiffe still gelegte orte
straßen und brücken die ins nirgendwo
führen der verlassene orte los places
haben eine einzigartige faszination jan
gespenstischen reiz heute abend ab 20.15
machen wir uns in der bild tv in der
spannenden doku reihe lost places auf
die suche nach diesen mysteriösen orten
schauen wir dann ausschnitt an bevor wir
mit dem lost places experten darüber
sprechen was diesen ganz speziellen kick
der verlassenen orte ausmacht
sie zählten zu den fortschrittlichsten
aufwerten der welt
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten haben
heute sind sie morsch verwittert
manchmal sogar gefährlich
brücken sind imposante bauwerke und
architektonischer meisterleistungen
sie überspannen breite täler um tiefe
abgründe
die colorado wüste in kalifornien
hier sind die tage eines verborgenen
ganz stücks der konstrukteurs technik
gezählt
canyon tressel ist etwas ganz besonderes
der wilde westen wie er leibt und lebt
ein klassisches stück amerikanischer
geschichte mitten in der wüste
ein tschechischer stausee mit einer
brücke die im volksmund hitler brücke
heißt
[Musik]
ohne die millionen kubikmeter wasser
sehe man sofort warum
hitler wollte sämtliche teile seines
reichs miteinander verbinden das hatte
natürlich auch militärische gründe egal
wo eine bedrohung auftauchte die truppen
sollten so schnell wie möglich dort
seien
die einmal höchste brücke der welt die
innerhalb einer minute einstürzte
[Musik]
im grunde wurde sie vom wind angehoben
und herumgewirbelt
wer sich diese trümmer ansieht weiß die
stabilität von stahl erst richtig zu
schätzen und
eine unsichtbare brücke in kapstadt über
die nie ein auto gerollt ist
die reichen aus kapstadt vorstädten
sollten auf ihrem weg zur arbeit über
die ärmeren stadtteile regelrecht hinweg
schweben
[Musik]
lost places das sind aber natürlich
nicht nur brücken das in stockhäuser
oder alte krankenhäuser aber was steckt
eigentlich hinter diesem hype warum
interessieren sich eigentlich so viele
menschen dafür was reizt uns an diesen
oftmals sehr sehr große ding orten das
wollen wir jetzt besprechen und zwar mit
dem experten schlechthin dr peter hohen
haus befasst sich seit 15 jahren
intensiv mit dunklen orten dark tourism
so heißt auch seine website und einen
atlas der düsteren reiseziele hat er
auch verfasste den atlas of dark and
destinations also eine große sammlung
mystische orte auf der ganzen welt herr
dr hohen haus wann spricht man
eigentlich von lost places
also vorweg muss man dazu sagen das ist
ja so ein pseudo anglizismus
im echten eigentlich heißt dass banden
places also es geht um verlassene orte
nicht wirklich verlorene orte wenn sie
einmal verloren sondern gibt es sicher
nicht mehr also wenn man zb an den
palast der republik in berlin denkt er
ist abgerissen worden dass es dann
wirklich los also es geht um verlassene
orte die man noch betreten kann die mehr
oder weniger
zugänglich sind oder auch eben auch
nicht zu wirklich und die über eine
gewisse anziehung aus auch viele leute
und das kann ich auch nachvollziehen ich
habe das schon seit seit kindestagen
eigentlich dass mich also verfallene
industrie wie fasziniert und anzieht und
wenn man die dann besuchen kann dann ist
das immer sehr spannend weil es eben
auch so ein kontrast ist zum üblichen
tourismus
also wenn man jetzt zum beispiel im
alten krankenhaus umhergeht in dem noch
krankenbetten stehen und medikamenten
schränke da geht dann einen film im kopf
an oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen
der mann ist dann ja in dem film also
ich erinnere mich da insbesondere an
meinen dritten besuch in tschernobyl da
ist die die geisterstadt pripjat das war
die stadt die für die arbeiter in dem
akw gebaut worden war mal etwa 50.000
leute haben dort gelebt und ist ja einen
tag nach der explosion dort evakuieren
worden steht seither leer und ich war
wie gesagt drei mal schon dort und das
letzte mal gehörte dazu auch das eines
der krankenhäuser und das war in der tat
beeindruckend
weil es eben so ein großer kontrast es
zu einem im betrieb befindlichen
krankenhaus da ist es da es geht es ja
immer willig zu hektisch viele leute
laut und plötzlich ist man in so einem
ort und er ist leer und leise also sturm
totenstill aber es stehen da noch die
betten mehr oder weniger verrottet ist
ja nun schon 35 jahre her aber man sie
tatsächlich auch noch medikamenten
schränke und geht dann dort durch und es
ist also es hat was von private
archäologie auch
kenny denn zu solchen orten einfach
hingehen sind sie überhaupt öffentlich
zugänglich das kommt drauf an also in
tschernobyl ist ist so dass man
offiziell natürlich eine eine
genehmigung braucht und auch eine auf
einer geführten tour sein muss und die
unterscheiden sich sehr stark also die
üblichen
tagestouren von gf aus die sind gerade
mal zwei stunden in der zone da sieht
man nicht viel und man ist in der großen
gruppe mit sell viel machen und so dass
da kriegt man von der geisterstadt
eigentlich nicht viel mehr dafür braucht
man eine private tour möglichst auch
mehrtägig und dann kriegt man wirklich
die einblicke die man die man dann auch
wirklich auch fotografisch ja sein muss
kann es ist ja um handlungen gemeinden
fotogenes das sind gibt es auch
spezielle fototouren dort
es gibt aber auch leute die das illegal
besuchen die sogenannten stalker die
sich also nicht um eine genehmigung
bemüht sondern nachts illegal die grenze
übertreten und dann dort alleine
herumstöbern und dann gibt es natürlich
andere orte jetzt die beelitz
heilstätten auch ein ehemaliges
sanatorium das dann als militärlazarett
gedient hat für die sowjettruppen in der
ddr und dann als die abzogen die 90ern
stand das erst mal lange lehrt und wurde
dann zu einem anziehungspunkt für
sogenannte airbags all das steht für die
exploration das ist ein bisschen
irreführender begriff weil das so oft ja
gar in städten wie nahe legen würde
stattfindet und die haben dann dort
diese verlassenen orte besucht und
fotografiert das hat immer sehr viel mit
fotografie auch zu tun
und dort hat sich aber sehr verändert
also das war lange zeit eine wilde
spielwiese für besser gab es für
vandalismus und graffiti und alles
inzwischen aber sind viele gebäude nach
genutzt zum teil auch wieder medizinisch
und ein teil ist jetzt
touristisch erschlossen worden das heißt
es gibt da einen sogar baumwipfelpfad
man kann also an einer der größten
ruinen des ganzen komplexes daher sehr
groß ist sozusagen aus der
vogelperspektive hineingucken und
zusätzlich gibt es für uns angebote
wobei die führung in der ehemaligen
chirurgie die die spannendste ist weil
man dann eben auch wieder dieses diesen
effekt eines verlassenen krankenhauses
hat zusätzlich da noch alles in mit
kyrillischen schriftzeichen die man
immer noch finden kann es hat also auch
so was von einer zeitreise in die
sowjetzeit zurück was man in pripjat
übrigens in beide richtungen hat es ist
einerseits eine zeitreise in die
vergangenheit
so jetzt seid von relikten offenbar aber
eben auch eine zeitreise in die zukunft
also in eine post zivilisatorische die
historische welt wenn die menschheit
sich dann weil ausgerottet hat wird es
so wie es im privat jetzt schon aussieht
überall aussehen insofern hat man also
auch eine zeitreise in die zukunft also
faszinierende reise danke für diese
einblicke alles heute abend ab 19 uhr 25
in der großen bild doku-reihe lost
places hierbei bild tv